we mentioned it there you went into
number 10 and you spoke to the prime
ministers among others about the state
of the NHS thinking to the picture of
you standing on the gates of Downing
Street how was the meeting
um so we're really pleased that it's
been acknowledged at the highest level
and it's pleased that we recognize
there's a crisis because there was a
crisis in emergency medicine we know uh
and this crisis is much worse you know
every winter we seem to go through this
thing there's another a e crisis but
it's important to recognize that what's
going on at the moment is much worse
than the graphs that you were putting up
beforehand showed that yeah and the
visible markers are ambulances waiting
outside hospitals but that is only a
visible marker of the whole system of
being under stress and what we're seeing
is if you go into the emergency
department you'll see the people being
looked after in inappropriate areas with
long ways to be admitted and if you go
onto the wards they're full and
fundamentally the big problem we've got
is as you you showed that we don't have
enough beds our hospitals are too full
for us to do the jobs that we need them
to do it's interesting because you
mentioned there about how we talk about
winter crisis all the time that this is
different and I have to say you know
I've been doing this job for some years
I've spoken to a lot of people working
in the house service at this time and it
feels quite different now I mean
frankly you know you guys seem quite
frightened is that true yes I mean it's
important that people realize that if
they think they need to seek help they
do seek help and one of the anxieties
that we have about all the frost that's
going on at the moment is that people
who are will sit at home when really
they should be seeking help that's
really important but at the same time
pretty much everyone I spoke to they
will say I've never seen it as bad as
this not even during the height of the
covert pandemic so in a very very
different way yes kovid was an
extraordinary time
and but all sorts of things went over it
this feels worse because it's so there's
so many bit strands to it and it's so
difficult and the long Waits that we've
got are water so dangerous and what
we're so worried about and you I mean I
guess the biggest thing people worry
about is safety about lives right and
you believe that lives are being lost
because of delays it's not just belief
so there's some scientific evidence to
back us up with papers that have been
published in scientific journals
everybody who's looked at this has
always found that when you start getting
long waits in emergency departments you
see an increase in mortality
um so there's reasonable scientific data
to support this but not only that we've
also got separate analyzes where people
have looked at ons data and have
suggested that the increase that we've
seen in excess mortality through this
year and there will be lots of factors
at play it's not one single thing but
there'll be lots of factors it's
entirely plausible and it shows this so
we think that problems accessing urgent
and emergency care whether calling an
ambulance waiting a long time for that
being anxious about going to hospital or
the long way to an emergency departments
will be contributing to about a third or
a quarter of all this excess mortality
and you believe that's 300 500 people a
week yeah I mean it will vary but in a
way actually if the number doesn't
matter no you know it's actually not
what we do about it yeah and we know it
shows that there's a problem that needs
fixing okay and just before we go on to
what we should do because I am very keen
to get your view on that and you know
when you talk to ministers and the
government they talk about covert an
awful lot and they say look this is
because of covid because the pressures
we had during covert because of people
playing you know getting appointments
Etc
is that true or do these problems go
back longer oh the problem is go back
way longer yeah if if you look at
performance indicators where we've been
having problems covert absolutely is yet
an additional thing and it's providing
it's taking a lot of disruption onto
hospitals but the problems that we're
holding this go back 2015 you know we
knew that this was a pun before but if
you go back before 2015 we did not have
problems with ambulance Handover delays
we did not have very often people
spending more than 12 hours in emergency
departments and is that under investment
so it's a variety of things
fundamentally the big problem is that we
just our hospitals are too full and you
put up that graph of not having enough
beds but also we're not using those beds
properly and actually in terms of what
we do with our beds we need to make sure
we're using those beds absolutely it's
efficiently and properly as possible
which I know part of that of course is
social care
um kirstama also talks on the program
today about using more capacity in the
private sector do you think that's a
good idea I think we we're in a state of
crisis at the moment and anything we can
do to reduce occupancy within hospitals
is the right thing to do it feels like
an expensive way to try and get
ourselves out of a pickle and I think
long term we've got to look at how we
actually stop this happening again and
that means actually getting to a
probably a more cost effective way to
try and do this by reforming the way we
do social care in this country and I'm
interested to know your thoughts on what
needs to happen in the short term but
also in the long term what do you think
needs to be done so it the big question
but fundamentally the thing we need to
do is reduce the occupancy in our
hospitals and that means having more
hospital beds and using those beds
better so fundamentally that's the big
problem that requires investment that
means also it's not just beds but it's
the workforce to look after them and we
do need to expand our Workforce
um you know and that's right across the
patch
um the government did announce more
money for the NHS in November Crawford
was talking about that an extra 3.3
billion pounds in each of the next two
years and I guess some would argue that
you know it's not just about money it's
not just about putting more and more
money into the NHS it's about reform too
otherwise the money effectively is
wasted do you think that's true I think
that's fair I mean I I you know the NHS
is an enormous organization and there's
always things that we can do differently
and think innovatively about how we do
this and I think that's a fair challenge
that we need we need to do it but
repairing something that's broken cost a
lot of money
so more money is part of the issue that
reformed to yes but you're dealing with
something that's fundamentally just very
very fragile and broken and that takes a
lot of work and you know
short-term big payments to try and buy
um uh aren't the way to do it we
actually need sustained predictable
funding so we can use that well rather
than just and that means things like
Capital funding and actually building
capacity not just on short-term salary
fixes and just looking forward I know
you don't want to talk directly about
strikes which I understand there are
meetings going on uh tomorrow and our
strikes also having an impact on you
know the safe running of the NHS well we
need to have a sense of perspective you
know we've been in trouble for the last
for the last year we had three strike
those days in December we're only having
four strike days yes they're disruptive
yes
um they're they're difficult but you've
got a much bigger picture of terrible
working conditions that have been going
on before